>> SO I AM JOINED NOW BY
ROWVAUGHN AND RODNEY WELLS, THE
PARENTS OF MR. NICHOLS HERE, OF
TYRE NICHOLS AND ALSO BENJAMIN
CRUMP, THE FAMILY ATTORNEY.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU'RE HOLDING
UP AND ABLE TO DO THIS UNDER
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> Reporter: I'M DOING AS WELL
AS CAN BE EXPECTED.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW.
I'M STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
ALL OF THIS AND TRYING TO WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND ALL OF THIS.
IT'S STILL LIKE A NIGHTMARE
RIGHT NOW.
SO --
>> JUST TO BE HONEST, LISTEN,
JUST CONDUCTING THIS INTERVIEW,
I'M A MAMA'S BOY, I WAS ALSO A
SKATER, A SKATEBOARDER GROWING
UP.
AND SO I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE MY
MOTHER DEALING WITH THIS, WHEN
YOU WALKED IN, YOU SAID, DON,
I'M NOT VERY GOOD AT THIS, AND I
SAID, I'VE GOT YOU.
WHO WOULD BE GOOD AT THIS?
>> EXACTLY.
>> WHO WOULD BE GOOD AT THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE THIS IS
VERY DIFFICULT.
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT.
>> YEAH.
>> YES.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING, DAD?
>> I'M HANGING IN THERE.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO BE STRONG
FOR THE FAMILY.
SO, WE HAVE OTHER SIBLINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO BE STRONG FOR ALSO.
>> DID YOU HEAR THE CHIEF?
>> YES.
>> WHAT'D YOU THINK?
>> I RESPECTED WHAT SHE SAID.
SHE'S DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB, I
FEEL.
SHE'S MOVING THINGS ALONG AND I
JUST, I LIKE WHAT SHE'S DOING.
>> SHE SAID THAT THERE HAS BEEN
NOTHING, NO EVIDENCE THAT THEY
HAVE FOUND SO FAR TO
SUBSTANTIATE WHY THE OFFICERS
STOPPED TYRE NICHOLS.
NO EVIDENCE SO FAR.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S TELLING, BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MUCH VIDEOTAPE
AMERICA'S ABOUT TO SEE, OVER OUR
LAW.
VIDEO FROM A CAMERA THAT CATCHES
A LOT OF THE TRAGEDY.
ALL OF THIS BODY CAM FOOTAGE.
IF TYRE WAS DRIVING RECKLESS, WE
SHOULD SEE IT.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THEY'RE
ALIGNED, BUT WE SHOULD SEE IT.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY CAN'T
SHOW IT TO US FURTHER
UNDERSCORES WHY THIS WAS SO
UNNECESSARY.
SO UNNECESSARY.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS.
BECAUSE LIKE MISS WELLS SAID,
HOW SWIFTLY THEY MOVED IN
MEMPHIS, AND HOW SWIFTLY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BROUGHT
CHARGES AGAINST THESE FIVE BLACK
POLICE OFFICERS.
THIS IS NOW THE BLUEPRINT FOR
AMERICA WHEN YOU SEE OFFICERS
COMMITTING CRIMES ON VIDEO, THEN
YOU CAN'T TELL US THAT YOU'VE
GOT TO GO SIX MONTHS, YOU'VE GOT
TO GO A YEAR.
NO, IT WAS THESE BLACK OFFICERS,
WE SAW IT MOVE SWIFTLY.
AND SO, THINK ABOUT ALL THE ONES
WE COVERED, DON.
I MEAN, THE TAMARA RICES,
AHMAUD, ALL OF THESE CASES TOOK
SO LONG, PHILANDO CASTILE FOR
THEM TO CHARGE.
BUT HERE IN MEMPHIS, WE DONE
HAVE THE BLUEPRINT THAT IT CAN
BE DONE SWIFTLY AND EFFICIENTLY.
>> YOU'RE SHAKING YOUR HEAD IN
AGREEMENT AND SAYING "YES."
WHY?
>> BECAUSE, JUST THE WAY THEY
MOVED SO FAST, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY COULDN'T DO
THAT IN OTHER CASES.
BUT, JUST TO KNOW THAT THEY
MOVED AS FAST AS THEY DID LETS
US KNOW THAT IT CAN BE DONE.
>> YOU WANTED FIRST-DEGREE
MURDER CHARGES.
>> YES.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET THAT?
>> NO.
THE CHARGES THAT WERE FILED
AGAINST THOSE OFFICERS ARE GOOD
CHARGES.
THOSE ARE THE CHARGES THAT I
FEEL WILL STICK.
AND SO, I'M HAPPY WITH THE
CHARGES THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HAS SET FORTH.
>> 20 DAYS SINCE THIS HAPPENED.
>> YES.
>> WITHOUT YOUR BABY.
YES.
THIS IS HARD.
NO, I DON'T HAVE MY BABY.
I'LL NEVER HAVE MY BABY AGAIN,
BUT I DO KNOW THAT HE WAS A GOOD
PERSON AND THAT ALL OF THIS, ALL
THE GOOD IN TYRE WILL COME OUT.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT KEEPS ME
GOING, BECAUSE, I JUST FEEL LIKE
MY SON WAS SENT HERE ON
ASSIGNMENT FROM GOD, AND HIS
ASSIGNMENT WAS OVER.
IT'S OVER.
AND HE WAS SENT BACK HOME AND
GOD IS NOT GOING TO LET ANY OF
HIS CHILDREN'S NAMES GO IN VAIN.
SO WHEN THIS IS ALL OVER, IT'S
GOING TO BE SOME GOOD AND SOME
POSITIVE, BECAUSE MY SON WAS A
GOOD AND POSITIVE PERSON.
AND THAT'S WHAT KEEPS ME GOING.
>> HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANY SLEEP?
>> NOT REALLY, BUT IT'S WHAT IT
IS.
>> MOM, WHEN DID YOU FIRST LEARN
ABOUT THIS?
HOW DID YOU HEAR?
>> THE MEMPHIS POLICE DEPARTMENT
BANGED ON OUR DOOR APPROXIMATELY
BETWEEN 8:30 AND 9:00, ASKING IF
WE KNEW TYRE NICHOLS.
AND WE SAID, YES, WHAT'S GOING
ON?
HE'S BEEN ARRESTED.
ARRESTED FOR WHAT.
DUI.
DUI?
MY SON DON'T DRINK LIKE THAT?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, DUI?
WELL, WE HAD TO PEPPER SPRAY HIM
AND TAZE HIM SO, HE'S BEING
ATTENDED TO BY THE PARAMEDICS
AND WE'LL SEND HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL AND THEN AFTER THAT,
HE'LL GO TO BOOKING.
WHAT?!
THEY THEN ASKED ME, WAS HE ON
ANY TYPE OF DRUGS OR ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE, BECAUSE HE WAS --
THEY WERE SAYING THAT IT WAS SO
ON HIM AND HE HAD THIS AMOUNT OF
ENERGY --
>> SUPERHUMAN ENERGY.
AND WHAT THEY WERE DESCRIBING
WAS NOT MY SON.
SO I WAS VERY CONFUSED.
I ASKED IF I CAN GO TO THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY TOLD ME, NO.
THEY LEFT.
MY HUSBAND AND I, WE GOT IN OUR
CAR AND WENT TO GO SEE IF WE
COULD FIND TY, BECAUSE HE WASN'T
ANSWERING HIS PHONE OR ANYTHING.
WHEN I ASKED THEM WHERE MY SON
WAS, THEY SAID NEARBY.
NEARBY?
WHAT IS NEARBY?
I GOT NOTHING FROM THEM.
I THINK NOW THAT I'M ACTUALLY
PUTTING THINGS TOGETHER, I
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
COVER IT UP WHEN THEY FIRST CAME
TO MY DOOR.
MM-HMM.
SO AROUND 4:00 IN THE MORNING,
THE DOCTORS CALLED FROM ST.
FRANCES AND SAID, MRS. WELLS, DO
YOU KNOW YOUR SON'S IN THE
HOSPITAL?
AND I SAID, YES, I WAS ADVISED
BY THE POLICE OFFICERS.
HE SAID, WHY AREN'T YOU HERE?
AND I SAID, THE POLICE OFFICERS
SAID THAT I COULDN'T COME,
BECAUSE HE WAS UNDER ARREST.
THE DOCTOR PROCEEDED TO TELL ME
THAT MY SON HAD WENT INTO
CARDIAC ARREST AND THAT HIS
KIDNEYS WERE FAILING.
THIS DOESN'T SOUND CONSISTENT TO
SOMEBODY BEING TASED OR PEPPER
SPRAYED.
WHEN MY HUSBAND AND I GOT TO THE
HOSPITAL AND I SAW MY SON, HE
WAS ALREADY GONE.
THEY HAD BEAT HIM TO A PULP.
HE HAD BRUISES ALL OVER HIM, HIS
HEAD WAS SWOLLEN LIKE A
WATERMELON, HIS NECK WAS BUSTING
BECAUSE OF THE SWELLING, THEY
BROKE HIS NECK, MY SON'S NOSE
LOOKED LIKE AN "S."
THEY ACTUALLY JUST BEAT THE CRAP
OUT OF HIM.
AND SO WHEN I SAW THAT, I KNEW
MY SON WAS GONE THEN, EVEN IF HE
DID LIVE, HE WOULD HAVE BEEN A
VEGETABLE.
SO ONCE I GOT TO THE HOSPITAL,
ALL THE POLICE OFFICERS WERE
BASICALLY WHISKED OUT, BECAUSE I
HEARD THAT THE TBI HAD TAKEN
OVER THE INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT WAS IT.
THEY SPOKE TO US, ASKED A BUNCH
OF QUESTIONS, BUT I KNEW
SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT.
I JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY STOPPED MY SON IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> YOU SAID THAT YOU THOUGHT
FROM THE INITIAL TIME WHEN THEY
CONTACTED YOU THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO COVER UP?
WHY DID YOU THINK THAT?
>> WELL, I DIDN'T THINK THAT
INITIALLY.
AS I STARTED GETTING INFORMATION
AND INFORMATION WAS COMING TO
ME, BECAUSE THEY MADE IT SEEM
LIKE THE STOP AND THE START --
THE START AND THE STOP OF THE --
WAS AT A CERTAIN LOCATION, WHEN
ACTUALLY THEY WERE LESS THAN 80
FEET FROM MY HOME.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAW.
NOW, I HATE TO BRING THIS UP,
BUT I JUST HAVE TO BE HONEST.
YOU KNOW EMMETT TILL.
>> YES.
>> IT'S REMINISCENT OF THAT.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THE VIDEO.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAW WHEN YOU WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL.
>> OH, YES.
YES.
>> DEFINITELY.
>> THAT WAS -- THAT WAS
TERRIBLE.
>> DAD, WOULD YOU AGREE WITH
THAT?
>> OH, MOST DEFINITELY.
BECAUSE I'M THE ONE WHO TOOK THE
PICTURE THAT'S BEING CIRCULATED.
AND I TOOK THE PICTURE BECAUSE
HE WAS IN SUCH A HORRIFIC
CONDITION.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN IN THAT
CONDITION FROM PEPPER SPRAY AND
TASING.
>> HE WAS NEVER CONSCIENCE?
YOU SAID YOU BELIEVED IF HE
LIVED, HE WOULD HAVE BEEN A
VEGE
VEGETABLE.
>> HE CALLS OUT FOR YOU THREE
TIMES.
GUT WRENCH ING.
>> SCREAMS.
>> GO AHEAD, MOM.
>> THAT WAS MY BABY.
HE WAS A MAMA'S BOY.
THAT BOY LOVED ME TO DEATH.
HE HAS MY NAME TATTOOED ON HIS
ARM.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
FIVE POLICE OFFICERS DID TO OUR
FAMILY.
AND THEY REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY DID TO THEIR OWN FAMILIES.
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR OWN FAMILIES
IN HARM'S WAY.
THEY HAVE BROUGHT SHAME TO THEIR
OWN FAMILIES.
THEY HAVE BROUGHT SHAME TO THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
I JUST FEEL SORRY FOR -- I FEEL
SORRY FOR THEM.
I REALLY DO.
I REALLY FEEL SORRY FOR THEM.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
DO THIS.
AND LIKE I SAID, THEY BROUGHT A
LOT OF SHAME TO THEIR OWN
FAMILY.
ONCE YOU SEE THIS VIDEO AND I
KNOW I DIDN'T SEE IT, BUT FROM
WHAT I HEAR, IT'S HORRIFIC!
AND THE HUMANITY OF IT ALL.
WHERE WAS THE HUMANITY?
THEY BEAT MY SON LIKE A PINATA.
MY SON, HE WAS -- HE HAD CROHN'S
DIS
DISEASE, HE HAD SURGERY IN 2013.
MY SON WEIGHED A BUCK 50.
HE WAS 6'3" AND HE WEIGHED A
BUCK FIFTY.
AND THOSE MEN, IF YOU COMBINE
THEIR WEIGHTS, THEY ALL -- IT
WAS OVER A THOUSAND POUNDS,
BEATING AND BEATING A 150-POUND
PERSON TO DEATH.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
THEY BEAT MY SON TO DEATH.
>> HE CRIED OUT FOR HIS MOM.
>> YES.
>> YES, HE CRIED OUT FOR ME,
BECAUSE I'M HIS MOTHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO
GET HOME TO SAFETY.
AND IT WAS FUNNY, I WAS IN THE
ROOM EARLIER, AND MY STOMACH
STARTED HURTING SO BAD, AND I
WENT INTO THE DEAN AND I TOLD MY
HUSBAND, MY STOMACH IS HURTING
SO BAD.
AND ONCE I FOUND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED, IT WAS JUST THE FACT
THAT I WAS FEELING MY SON'S
PAIN.
I WAS FEELING MY SON'S PAIN WHEN
THEY WERE BEATING HIM TO DEATH.
>> YOU SAID THAT YOU FELT SORRY
FOR THEM.
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM, MOM?
>> I DON'T -- I DON'T -- I DON'T
HATE ANYBODY.
THAT'S NOT IN MY NATURE.
I JUST FEEL SORRY FOR THEM,
BECAUSE THEY DID SOMETHING
HORRENDOUS AND -- I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU SAID THEY BROUGHT SHAME
ON THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILY, AND
YOU -- MAY BROUGHT SHAME ON THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO -- THESE WERE
ALL BLACK OFFICERS.
>> PEOPLE TRY TO SAY BLACK
PEOPLE, WE ONLY TRY TO GO AFTER
WHITE OFFICERS.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE DON'T CARE WHAT COLOR THE
OFFICER IS.
WE WANT BAD OFFICERS TAKEN OFF
THE FORCE.
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT
OFFICERS, I KNOW OFFICERS.
BUT THERE ARE BAD OFFICERS, TOO.
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE
NEED TO GET RID OF.
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE KIDS THAT
ARE DYING AND BEING KILLED AT
THE HANDS OF POLICE OFFICERS,
THEIR PARENTS PAY TAXES.
THEY'RE PAYING THEIR SALARIES.
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO BE
MURDERED BY A PERSON WHO THEY'RE
PAYING THEIR SALARIES?
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
WHY IS IT THAT BLACK AND BROWN
KIDS ALWAYS GET BEAT UP WHEN
THEY ARE ENCOUNTERED WITH THE
POLICE?
WE JUST HAD AN INCIDENT IN
MEMPHIS RIGHT AFTER MY SON, WITH
THE WHITE GUY WHO SPIT ON POLICE
OFFICER.
THEY DIDN'T BEAT HIM TO DEATH.
WHY?
AND I'M NOT SAYING THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO, BUT WHY?
THEY RAN, THEY DIDN'T GET BEAT
UP.
I DON'T CARE WHAT COLOR OF
POLICE OFFICER, BUT BY THEM
BEING BLACK, IT HURT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
>> AND YOU THINK THERE'S A BIAS
BUILT INTO THE SYSTEM REGARDLESS
OF WHAT COLOR THE OFFICER IS?
>> YES, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THESE OFFICERS, MOM?
>> I WOULD SAY TO THESE OFFICERS
THAT YOU HAVE TO SHOW SOME
COMPASSION TO PEOPLE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT A LOT OF THESE
POLICE OFFICERS INTIMIDATE BLACK
PEOPLE IN ORDER FOR THEM TO DO
SOMETHING.
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THEM TO DO
AND THEY NEED TO LEARN THAT
EVERYONE IS HUMAN AND EVERYONE
SHOULD BE TREATED WITH RESPECT.
>> YES.
YES.
>> SHE DIDN'T SEE THE VIDEO.
YOU SAW THE VIDEO?
>> YES.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SEE,
RODNEY?
>> FROM THE INITIAL ENCOUNTER --
>> YOU CAN'T EVEN LOOK THAT WAY
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT THE VIDEO.
>> I DIDN'T WANT HER -- I DIDN'T
WANT HER TO SEE THE VIDEO OR
HEAR THE VIDEO.
IT WAS OUR ATTORNEYS' REQUEST
THAT SHE STAY IN THERE AS LONG
AS SHE COULD.
SHE HEARD ONE WORD AND HAD TO
LEAVE OUT OF THE ROOM.
AND THAT WAS WHEN THEY INITIALLY
PULLED HIM OUT OF THE CAR, HE
SAID, WHAT DID I DO?
>> I KNEW THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> HE SAID, WHAT DID I DO?
WHY ARE Y'ALL DOING THIS TO ME?
WHAT DID I DO?
AND THEY PROCEEDED TO SNATCH HIM
OUT OF THE CAR AND WAS TRYING TO
WRESTLE HIM TO THE GROUND.
AND HE GOT SCARED.
SO HE WAS ATHLETIC ENOUGH TO GET
OUT OF THEIR SITUATION AND RUN.
AND HE WAS TRYING TO RUN HOME,
BECAUSE HE WAS THREE BLOCKS FROM
THE HOUSE WHEN THEY STOPPED HIM.
SO AFTER THE INITIAL
ENCOUNTER -- WE DIDN'T SEE
EVERYTHING, BECAUSE ACTUALLY
WHEN THE BODY CAM STARTED, THEY
WERE ALREADY ENGAGED.
AND THEN THERE WAS THE SECOND
BODY CAM WITH THE SKY CAM THAT
GOT THE ENCOUNTER.
AND WHEN I SAW THE POLICE
OFFICER, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE
THIS LITTLE LIKE STICK, THIS
METAL THING THAT THEY PULL OUT.
>> THEY PULL OUT -- LIKE AN
ANTENNA.
>> RETRACTABLE.
>> I SAW THEM PULL THAT OUT AND
STARTED BEATING MY SON WITH IT.
AND I SAW OFFICERS HITTING ON
HIM, I SAW OFFICERS KICKING HIM.
ONE OFFICER KICKED HIM LIKE HE
WAS KICKING A FOOTBALL, A COUPLE
OF TIMES.
BUT THE MOST, THE MOST TELLING
THING ABOUT THE VIDEO TO ME WAS
THE FACT THAT IT WAS MAYBE TEN
OFFICERS ON THE SCENE AND NOBODY
TRIED TO STOP IT OR EVEN AFTER
THEY BEAT HIM AND THEY PROPPED
HIM UP AGAINST THE CAR, NO ONE
RENDERED AID TO HIM WHATSOEVER.
THEY WALKED AROUND, SMOKING
CIGARETTES LIKE IT WAS ALL CALM
AND LIKE, YOU KNOW, BRAGGING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> AN HOUR OF VIDEO.
>> YES.
>> AND YOU SAW HIM JUST SITTING
THERE.
>> HE WAS SITTING THERE, AND
THEN HE SLUMPED OVER.
AND AN OFFICER WALKED OVER TO
HIM AND SAID, SIT BACK UP!
MOTHER -- MF, YOU KNOW, WHILE
HE'S HANDCUFFED.
SO HE HAD TO -- THEY PROP HIM
BACK UP, AND HE SLUMPED OVER
AGAIN, AND THEY PROP HIM BACK UP
AGAIN, BUT NO ONE WAS RENDERING
AID.
I SAW SOME FIRE DEPARTMENT
PEOPLE COME OUT THERE AND THEY
JUST WALKED AROUND AND NOBODY
SHOWED HIM ANY AID, AND THEY
SUPPOSED TO BE TRAINED IN FIRST
AID.
BY THE TIME THE PARAMEDIC TRUCK
PULLED UP, THAT'S WHEN WE
COULDN'T SEE ANYTHING BECAUSE
THE PARAMEDIC TRUCK BLOCKED THE
CAMERA.
SO I WAS TOLD THAT THE LADY WHO
WAS DRIVING THE PARAMEDIC TRUCK
NEVER GOT OUT.
>> SAD.
>> SO IT WAS -- IT WAS JUST --
YOU KNOW, TO WATCH YOUR SON, AS
WE STATE ALL THE TIME, 150
POUNDS, HOW COULD HE POSE A
THREAT TO THEIR LIVES TO WHERE
THEY HAD TO TAKE HIS LIFE?
>> UNARMED.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE?
>> MY MESSAGE IS, AS MY WIFE
SAID, HOPEFULLY FROM THIS
SITUATION, THAT WE HAVE REFORM.
THAT POLICE GET BETTER TRAINING.
THAT, YOU KNOW, I'VE HEARD FROM
PEOPLE, BECAUSE OF THIS, WHERE
THIS PARTICULAR UNIT --
>> SCORPION.
>> SCORPION UNIT HAS BEAT UP
OTHER PEOPLE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DIE,
IT'S NOT PUBLICIZED.
IT'S WASHED UNDER THE RUG.
>> YOU THINK MORE IS GOING TO
COME OUT THEN?
>> I BELIEVE THAT MORE IS GOING
TO COME OUT AND IT'S GOING TO BE
A STRONG REACTION, DON LEMON.
AFTER GEORGE FLOYD, AFTER SO
MANY OF THESE TRAGEDIES, WE
PRAYED FOR REFORM.
>> CAN I ASK YOU SOMETHING?
SHE SAID HER SON CAME HERE ON A
MISSION.
AND SHE DOESN'T HATE ANYBODY.
SHE FEELS SORRY FOR THEM.
DOING THE WORK THAT YOU DO, IS
THERE A LESSON -- YOU SAID THIS
SHOULD BE A BLUEPRINT FOR AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
SO IF -- WHAT IS THE MISSION,
WHAT WILL ACCOMPLISH THE MISSION
THAT SHE BELIEVES THAT HER SON
WAS SENT TO THIS EARTH FOR AND
TAKEN TOO QUICKLY?
>> AND THE PRAYER THAT I BELIEVE
MISS WELLS IS ARTICULATING IS
THAT THIS WON'T HAVE TO HAPPEN
TO OTHER YOUNG BLACK AND BROWN
CHILDREN.
WE GONNA HAVE TO LEARN SO MANY
HASHTAGS, DON LEMON, I HAVE TO
KEEP TALKING TO YOU ON CNN, WEEK
AFTER EVERY OTHER WEEK ABOUT YET
ANOTHER UNARMED BLACK PERSON HAS
BEEN KILLED BY POLICE IN A
HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL MANNER.
HOPEFULLY THIS INSTITUTION AL
POLICE IS SAYING IT'S OKAY TO
ENGAGE IN EXCESSIVE FORCE
AGAINST BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
WILL FINALLY BE DEL WITH.
WE WON'T CONTINUE TO TRY TO SAY
THAT, OH, IT'S TRAINING.
THEY CAN DE-ESCALATE JUST FINE
WHEN IT'S WHITE CITIZENS.
WE SEE THAT ALL THE TIME.
BUT IT'S WHEN IT'S BLACK AND
BROWN CITIZENS, NO MATTER IF THE
POLICE ARE BLACK, HISPANIC, OR
WHITE, THEY SEEM TO DO THE MOST,
DON LEMON.
AND SO THIS IS THE BLUEPRINT
FROM NOW, YOU KNOW.
MEMPHIS POLICE DEPARTMENT
TERMINATED THEM IMMEDIATELY.
THE DA BROUGHT CHARGES WITHIN 20
DAYS.
NOW, WHEN IT'S NOT BLACK
OFFICERS, WE WANT TO SEE THE
SAME TYPE OF JUSTICE.
>> MOM?
>> YES?
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO MISS
ABOUT HIM THE MOST?
>> HIS BEAUTIFUL SMILE.
AND JUST, MY SON HAD A BEAUTIFUL
SOUL AND HE TOUCHED A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
AND I ALWAYS JOKE, BECAUSE HE'LL
COME IN THE HOUSE, AND HE'LL
COME IN AND SAY, HELLO, PARENTS.
I'LL NEVER HEAR THAT AGAIN.
I'LL NEVER COOK FOR MY SON
AGAIN.
I'LL NEVER GET A HUG FROM MY SON
I WON'T GET ANYTHING FROM MY SON
AGAIN.
JUST BECAUSE SOME OFFICERS
DECIDED THEY WANTED TO DO HARM
TO MY SON.
AND SO, THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT
THING.
NO MOTHER SHOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS.
NO MOTHER.
AND I NEVER THOUGHT IN A MILLION
YEARS THAT I WOULD BE SITTING ON
YOUR SHOW, SPEAKING ABOUT MY
DECEASED SON THAT WAS KILLED BY
THE MEMPHIS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YOU ONLY GET ONE MOM.
>> YES.
>> AND I JUST -- I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
JUST SO YOU KNOW, I SAID I WAS A
SKATER GROWING UP.
MY MOM IS WITH ME NOW, VISITING
FROM LOUISIANA.
>> OH.
>> HER BOYFRIEND, FOUND HER DEAD
ON CHRISTMAS EVE, AND SHE'S BEEN
WITH ME FOR TWO MONTHS, AND
SHE'S STAYING WITH ME AND I
RELATE TO WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
YOU, ESPECIALLY A BLACK FAMILY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER THE RACE OF
THE OFFICER.
NO ONE DESERVES TO BE TREATED
LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN BE COOPTED NO MATTER
WHAT RACE BY A SYSTEM THAT IS
BIASED.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING
THAT, BECAUSE THE WORLD SHOULD
KNOW IT DOESN'T MATTER THE RACE
OF THE OFFICER.
PEOPLE JUST WANT TO BE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND FAIRNESS.
AND FOR A TRAFFIC STOP, NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO DIE.
>> EXACTLY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY, THANK
YOU TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
BECAUSE HE'S WORKING VERY HARD
ON THIS.
AND HE WAS JUST ELECTED IN.
AND HE'S DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB,
AS WELL AS THE CHIEF OF POLICE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY, AS PAINFUL AS
THIS IS, WE HAVEN'T HEARD THIS
FAMILY ESPOUSE ONE OUNCE OF
HATE.
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> THEY CONTINUE TO SAY, WE JUST
FEEL TERRIBLE THAT THEY DID THIS
OUR CHILD.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT'S THE --
>> THANK YOU, BEN.
THANK YOU, RODNEY.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE